[Musique]
la princesse rouge c'était donc le titre
de ce documentaire et cette princesse
c'est Kim yo Jong la sœur du leader
nord-coréen Kim Jong-Un qui selon ce
film pourrait bien être amené à
remplacer son frère en cas d'empêchement
car chez l'équipe vous l'avez vu depuis
la création de la Corée du Nord soit
1948 la main mise sur le pouvoir est
avant toute chose une affaire de famille
un comble pour un régime communiste nous
allons en débattre maintenant avec nos
invités présents sur ce plateau des
Badoc en commençant par celui qui a
écrit et réalisé ce documentaire le
journaliste Pierre Aski bienvenue pierre
ASCII très heureux de vous retrouver
dans cette émission des badocs qui plus
est à l'occasion d'un film dont vous
êtes à la fois l'auteur et le
réalisateur vous édito géopolitique sont
à écouter chaque matin dans la matinale
de nos confrères de France Inter c'est à
8h17 très exactement tous les matins de
la semaine et nous allons rappeler que
vous également le président de reporter
sans frontières également avec nous
Marie oranger rivet bienvenue vous êtes
historienne spécialiste de la Corée
contemporaine enseignante à l'université
parité et membre du Centre de recherche
sur la Corée et puis enfin avec nous
Marianne peronoise bienvenue à vous vous
êtes chercheuses associés à l'Iris
l'Institut de relations internationales
et stratégiques et directrice de
l'Observatoire géopolitique sur l'Indo
Pacifique on va commencer comme à la
coutumée dans cette émission lorsqu'il
est question de géopolitique par une
carte pour resituer bien sûr la Corée du
Nord est plus exactement la République
populaire démocratique de Corée qui est
un état vous le voyez qui couvre la
partie nord de la péninsule coréenne
située en Asie du Nord-Est le pays
compte 25,3 millions d'habitants environ
c'est la moitié de son voisin du Sud la
Corée du Sud et la capitale est bien sûr
Pyongyang le pays est limitrophe de la
Chine avec une frontières immenses 1416
km de frontières communes avec la Chine
au nord avec la Russie 19 km de
frontières seulement on a envie de dire
mais une importance considérable de la
Russie et de bien sûr de l'Union
soviétique à l'époque on l'a vu dans ce
film et puis en face cette fameuse
frontière avec la Corée du Sud 238 km de
frontières avec cette fameuse ligne DMZ
dont il a été également beaucoup
question évidemment dans ce film qui est
une zone démilétarisée mais qui est en
réalité la plus forte zone militarisée
au monde car ils surveillée au total
aujourd'hui par environ un million de
soldats ce qui est évidemment
considérable pierre asci première
question qu'est-ce qui vous a donné
envie de faire ce documentaire est-ce
que
il s'agissait d'une certaine manière de
répondre aux rumeurs selon lequel Kim
jungle était malade en mauvais état de
santé et qu'il cette question de la
succession pouvait se poser il y a
encore quelques années alors ce qui m'a
donné envie c'est ce que vous avez dit
au début c'est à dire c'est la seule
dynastie à la tête d'un pays communiste
et essayer de comprendre complètement le
système
du pouvoir et donc par extension si
jamais le leader actuel venait à
disparaître brutalement ou être empêché
tout simplement ses enfants étant très
petit qui le remplacerait et c'est là
que qu'intervient cette sœur et ce qui
est formidable avec la Corée du Nord
c'est que tout est mis en scène tout est
filmé et tout est présenté au monde
d'une manière très chorégraphiée et donc
il y a beaucoup d'images et quand on
s'est plongé dans ces images on a vu
cette cette progression sur une décennie
de cette jeune fille dans l'arme au
moment de la mort de son père jusqu'à
cette femme pleine d'assurance qui
promet le le feu nucléaire à ses ennemis
et il y avait voilà quelque chose à
comprendre à la fois dans sa
personnalité à elle et je ne sais pas si
on arrive à la comprendre parce qu'elle
est en permanence en représentation en
tout cas dans ce qu'on envoie et puis
surtout
ce système dynastie donc ce cette ligne
du sang qui est effectivement dynamique
avec l'idée d'un régime communiste mais
on l'a compris la Corée du Nord n'est
pas un régime communiste classique on va
voir un premier extrait du documentaire
pireski il concerne le mont pectou et
l'explique ce qu'est cette lignée
dynastique chez l'équipe c'est le
berceau de la civilisation coréenne la
dynastie Kim serait approprié elle a
pris le contrôle du symbole du Mont
pectou qui lui permet de justifier son
pouvoir despotique en diffusant le
mensonge le mythe selon lequel la
famille est sacrée qu'ils sont les
sauveurs du peuple coréen et ont pour
mission de libérer la Corée du Sud que
la Corée du Nord considère comme une
colonie des États-Unis
tout pouvoir dynastie a besoin d'un
mythe fondateur et semi de fondateur de
la dynastie des Kim et finalement il
faut aller le trouver du côté du Mont
pectou vous pouvez nous expliquer sur
quoi repose cette légende c'est une
légende en réalité alors bien sûr c'est
une légende on parle de fondateurs des
royaumes coréens etc dans l'Antiquité
mais surtout ça permet de rassembler au
20e siècle des Coréens qui ont été un
petit peu
divisé au moment de la de la
colonisation japonaise bien sûr et puis
après avec cette antagonisme entre le
Nord et le Sud dès les années 5 et
l'arrivée de la guerre froide en fait
sur cette péninsule donc pour le nord
c'est très habile de mobiliser quelque
chose qui pourrait rassembler les
Coréens du Nord et du Sud qui est le
père fondateur le père fondateur de la
nation
a vécu une période de la résistance
contre les Japonais sur ce
ça c'est avéré alors sur le mont en tant
que tel peut-être pas assez sur tout en
Mandchourie ou en Chine ou bien en union
enfin oui en Union soviétique etc à
l'époque mais en tout cas ce qui est
très important c'est que les Coréens
peuvent se rassembler là il y a pas de
fracture idéologique éventuelles autour
de ce mythe du Mont pectou alors pierre
est-ce qu'il a dit c'est fortement bien
démontré dans ce documentaire c'est la
seule dynastie qui dirige un pays
communiste au monde est-ce que les
autres pays communistes ont un regard
particulier sur la du Nord et cette
fameuse dynastie qui dirig un pays
communiste écoutez oui elle est elle est
quand même assez assez particulière mais
quand on regarde l'environnement
asiatique on voit très souvent des
héritiers entre entre guillemets même si
quand même cela passe par un système de
désignation plus ou moins démocratique
par des élections j'ai quand même en
tête effectivement
Megawati qui a été donc la présidente
élue en Indonésie qui était la fille de
son père disons-le et puis pas si loin
que la Corée du Nord vous avez
effectivement madame Park la fille du
président général Park qui a été élu
dans un cadre extrêmement démocratique
donc on a quand même des exemples de
famille qui qui sont très proches du
pouvoir qui qui l'ont en quelque sorte
confisqué de façon je dirais plus ou
moins régulière et je n'oublierai pas de
mentionner l'exemple en Asie du Sud-Est
de des Philippines où on voit le fils
Marcos revenir au pouvoir après une
période intermédiaire donc non
finalement c'est ces grandes familles on
les voit mais la durée et la mise en
image qui vient d'être souligné propre à
la dynastie nord-coréenne et quand même
quelque chose d'assez unique et puis
aussi cette volonté de mettre en avant
une forme de mythologie parce que le mot
pacte tout voilà fait référence quand
même à une histoire très ancienne et
aussi une histoire récente qui est la
guerre de Corée avec le mythe du héros
révolutionnaire qui qui refonte ou qui
redonne une légitimité à la à la
dynastie avec cumulsung alors fondateur
qui est arrivé dans les bagages de
l'Union soviétique que vous l'avez aussi
rappelé dans ce film juste après la
Seconde Guerre mondiale
et ça dire que le parti du travailleur
de Corée on a vu ces formidable réunions
du comité central de ce de ce parti le
PTC pas strictement aucune influence sur
les sur l'avenir de ce pays sur les
successions possibles à la tête de ce
pays
l'importance du parti a beaucoup changé
selon les périodes il y a eu des
périodes où le parti était en déshérence
totale et en tout cas n'avait même pas
de fonctionnement de partie je pense que
c'est quand même une machine au service
des Kim et c'est la manière dont ça
s'est déroulé depuis 48 d'une certaine
manière il y a eu des luttes de clan il
y a eu des tendances il y a eu des
moments où des décisions ont dû être
prises mais depuis une vingtaine
d'années le parti n'est qu'une n'est
qu'un rouage de l'appareil du pouvoir
parce qu'on a vu aussi des luttes
d'influence dans le Parti communiste
chinois par exemple après Mao
ça pourrait se reproduire néanmoins chez
du côté de ce fameux parti du travail de
Corée ça paraît très difficile à
imaginer d'autant et on l'a vu dans le
film la manière dont
a traité son oncle ou son demi-frère
c'est-à-dire qu'il les a éliminés parce
qu'il constituait des dangers potentiels
peuvent servir de de mise en garde à
tous ceux qui
oseraient s'opposer à la dynastie c'est
un jeu auquel il vaut mieux réussir
parce que si on rate c'est fatal c'est
donc la répression du régime
un état complètement totalitaire qui
fait tenir cette dynastie aujourd'hui en
fait c'est l'incarnation dans les
leaders c'est-à-dire quelqu'un choisit
de la famille Kim qui est à la tête du
parti et qui en fait contrôle absolument
tout le pays donc c'est vraiment
pour voir une évolution du système il
faudrait à la limite changer de partie
cette machine du parti vraiment qui
contrôle la population vraiment à tous
les niveaux qui contrôlent l'état là
c'est extrêmement important et le
de la personnalité qui est vraiment
ancrée et divulgué à tous les étages
dans cette société c'est le parti qui
qui donne les commandements donc
vraiment le parti à mon sens et quand
même quelque chose de central c'est lui
aussi qui a les meilleurs éléments pour
faire évoluer le pays c'est-à-dire avoir
des ingénieurs pour tout simplement des
scientifiques pour développer les armes
avoir aussi et bien décharger de
communication qui se font un travail
colossal de propagande et à d'autres
niveaux également par exemple dans
l'éducation etc etc alors il n'en a pas
été question dans ce documentaire mais
il existe aussi un bureau
occulte appelé le bureau 39
identifié comme un bureau
administratif chargé de remonter toutes
les devises étrangères au régime et on
parle même de budget de deux économies
parallèles dans dans ce pays aujourd'hui
le budget de l'État nord-coréen et un
budget
issu de ce fameux bureau 39 qui serait
directement remontée à cette dynastie
des Kim tu aurais d'ailleurs un train de
vie qui n'aurait pas grand chose à voir
avec 90 communistes normal bien sûr
entre guillemets ça aussi c'est une
réalité de ce pays il y a deux économies
parallèles deux budget parallèles avec
ce fameux bureau 39 qui ramènerait des
devises pour financer
directement le programme nucléaire qui
est lui-même dirigé directement par
cette dynastie des clim a commencé que
par Kim jungle aujourd'hui oui oui c'est
très c'est très opaque ce fonctionnement
comme comme l'ensemble des principaux
rouages de ce de ce régime enfin il faut
bien avoir trouvé des revenus pour
alimenter par exemple ce très couteau
programme militaire ce programme
nucléaire donc qui est la grande œuvre
en fin de compte de la de la famille qui
est l'héritage en fait qui est repris
mis en avant et donc ça coûte énormément
d'argent pour un pays qui en fait depuis
des années sous embargo et qui n'a pas
de de fonctionnement économique qui ne
peut pas s'auto-alimenter qui est très
très loin de l'autosuffisance
alimentaire donc il dépend beaucoup de
l'aide extérieure
et donc une caisse noire entre
guillemets effectivement
tous les tous les diplomates qui sont à
l'étranger qui sont censés par
différents moyens qu'on imagine
évidemment illégaux que ce soit la vente
de passeport que ce soit
de crypto monnaie voilà
c'est vrai que les les fameux hackers de
Pyongyang aussi sont souvent montré du
doigt pratiques effectivement une
extorsion notamment en ce comment dire
en les réseaux de la de la Corée du Sud
afin de ramener de l'argent donc tous
les moyens sont bons effectivement pour
alimenter cette cette caisse noire
sachant que l'embargo étant de plus en
plus sévère il est très difficile en
fait de pouvoir par une activité
quelconque alimenter régulièrement le
régime on va voir deux extraits l'un
après l'autre première extrait nous
sommes en février 2018 les JO les Jeux
olympiques d'hiver ont lieu en Corée du
Sud et c'est là qu'apparaît la princesse
rouge
la délégation nord-coréenne est conduite
par un vétéran du régime qu'il n'y en a
mais la vraie sensation et la présence
de kimiot Jong
[Musique]
c'est la première fois qu'un membre de
la famille au pouvoir mais les pieds au
sud depuis la séparation en 1947 et la
jeune sœur du leader fait l'objet de
toutes les attentions
la fameuse princesse rouge la sœur de
Kim Jong-un nous sommes en 2018 4 ans
plus tard deuxième extrait du film la
voilà devant
les responsables du parti en Corée du
Nord
des combattants avec un esprit de combat
que les ennemis de classe et un leader
qui a pour unique mission de défendre le
front idéologique avec une
responsabilité plus lourde que jamais
nous nous préparons comme des Vengeurs
impitoyables dans nos cœurs nous
exercerons une puissance de feu plus
intense dans la droite ligne de notre
idéologie afin de punir nos ennemis ou
qu'ils soient
alors quel contraste quatre ans après
qui est la véritable kimiojon alors les
Sud-Coréens se le demandent parce que
quand ils ont vu arriver qui met autre
jongle aux Jeux Olympiques ça a été une
sensation extraordinaire relationné la
Madonna parce qu'elle a charmé la Corée
du Sud tous les talk-shauts de la
télévision sud-coréenne parler de son
sourire de sa veste de son sac de enfin
c'était une véritable sensation on
n'avait pas vu ça et les suites coréens
ont été convaincus à ce moment-là que
c'était le signe de la détente et que la
paix et la réconciliation étaient au
bout du chemin il y a eu un moment
d'illusion très fort il y avait une
administration en Corée du Sud qui était
favorable en tout cas une détente très
forte
et donc ce moment
a séduit les suites coréens et tout d'un
coup lorsqu'il y a eu la rupture des
négociations avec Donald Trump puisque
tout ça produit à des rencontres entre
Kim Jong-un et Donald Trump à Singapour
puis Hanoï il y a eu un changement de
temps complet qui a abouti à ce qu'on
vient de voir c'est à dire des diatribe
anti-impérialistes et là les suites
coréens sont dit mais qui est la vraie
qui met audience et en fait moi mon avis
c'est une réponse oui c'est qu'il y a
pas de vrai qui me dites une audience
selon la partition qu'il faut qu'elle
donne à un moment précis et qui
correspond aux intérêts du régime
c'est-à-dire qu'elle n'a pas elle n'est
pas elle ne se trahit pas quand elle est
souriante et elle ne se trahi pas quand
elle fait des diatribles elle est dans
son rôle de dirigeante nord-coréenne qui
correspond à un moment donné de la
géopolitique et des relations de la
Corée du Nord avec ses partenaires alors
kimiot Jong princesse rouge ou simple
pion du pouvoir c'est un peu la question
qu'on peut se poser ah mais c'est une
femme politique je pense que on l'a on
l'a compris on la voyant parce que que
ce soit la période de l'arrivée pour les
Jeux olympiques ou plus tard un retour à
une réalité à laquelle d'ailleurs la
Corée du Nord nous habitué c'est ce ces
grands discours qui dénoncent avec ce
vocabulaire très très outré en fait elle
a quand même une grande maîtrise on sent
chez elle quelqu'un qui
maîtrise les codes malgré tout nous nous
la découvrons c'est un nouveau visage
elle a quelque chose de fascinant parce
qu'elle est jeune parce que bien sûr
c'est une femme donc je pense que cette
fascination qu'on éprouvé les sucoréens
on a tous été
on l'a tous éprouvé à un degré
quelconque parce que elle incarne une
certaine forme de nouveautés en même
temps elle est elle est très maîtrisée
dans son apparence et donc il y a une
forme de continuité dans cette cette
présence pour la première fois et sa
présence dans un environnement qu'elle
maîtrise totalement qui est le sien lors
d'un comité des travailleurs de Corée
c'est un personnage politique je pense
que disparaîtra du paysage après les
échecs des négociations de de Hanoï
pendant un certain temps autrement dit
comme vous le disiez à l'instant elle
est au service du pouvoir elle service
de son frère
dans le documentaire c'est bien dit elle
a vraiment un rôle de soutien de son
frère son frère on l'a rappelé tout à
l'heure a fait le vide autour de lui en
éliminant son frère aîné son demi-frère
aîné et son oncle et donc c'est au sein
du clan des Kim et bien il y a eu un
nettoyage et du coup le leader actuel se
retrouve isolé et il a absolument besoin
de de garder un lien avec la population
qui qui le fait vivre finalement et avec
aussi les personnes du parti qui le
soutiennent et qui renforce son pouvoir
politique et de la manière dont elle est
perçue justement au sein de ce fameux
parti dont on a parlé tout à l'heure on
en a seulement la moindre idée vu son
attitude on a l'impression qu'elle est
montée dans les dans l'échelle de la
hiérarchie du parti et qu'elle est
quasiment au plus haut niveau j'ai vu
dans une interview vous disiez peu
importe son titre j'en ai trouvé un
allez directrice adjointe du département
propagandé agitations du parti du
travailleur de Corée les parieurs député
et j'ai vu dans une interview disait peu
importe son titre elle est de la de la
lignée
mais ce qui est intéressant et on le
voit bien dans le film c'est que elle
peut avoir une assurance quand elle est
seule quand elle est encore et du Sud ou
quand elle est
à la tribune d'amitié mais elle s'efface
dès qu'il est là c'est à dire que elle
est au service de son frère c'est le
frère le leader suprême et il n'y a pas
de discussion là-dessus et d'ailleurs je
pense que c'est le secret de leur
relation d'abord il faut ne pas oublier
qu'ils ont étudié ensemble en Suisse
quand ils étaient jeunes donc il y a un
lien particulier entre les deux qui
remonte à cette époque et et que dès
qu'il y a le moindre soupçon de rivalité
ou de ou de d'ambition ça se termine
comme avec le le demi-frère ou l'oncle
c'est-à-dire l'élimination et là on voit
bien qu'entre les deux il y a une il y a
une partition qui est parfaitement
réglée elle s'efface dès qu'il est là
alors on l'a souvent vu lié à des
affaires plutôt internationales
extérieur au pays
c'était vrai pour les rapprochements
entre les deux Corées les rencontres
vous l'avez dit les trois rencontres
entre Kim Jong-un et Trump est-ce
qu'elle était également présente lors de
la récente rencontre qui a eu lieu là en
Russie orientale entre Poutine et Kim
jungle alors Noël n'était pas présente
parce que les deux ne peuvent pas
voyager en même temps imaginons qu'il se
passe quelque chose de dramatique la
relève serait assurée et donc elle reste
à Pyongyang au cas où et je pense
qu'elle n'est pas indispensable dans un
dans un cas comme ça la rencontre avec
Trump était
il y avait une dimension de spectacle
donc il fallait que tout soit réglé
comme du papier à musique avec Poutine
on était quand même dans un registre
plus convenu la Russie est à un pays
avec lequel la Corée a des relations
historiques et avec Poutine on était
dans un une relation politique là qui
était liée au contexte de la guerre en
Ukraine etc donc elle n'était pas
présente parce qu'elle n'a pas elle n'a
pas besoin d'être présent dans un cas
comme ça alors ce que nous dit Pierre à
ce qui dans ce film c'est que finalement
ça serait elle en cas d'empêchement du
frère qui serait amené à prendre le
pouvoir et là je voudrais votre avis à
l'une et l'autre sachant que nous sommes
au sein et nous parlons d'un pays où la
tradition patriarcale est extrêmement
forte et soulignée par tous les experts
de ce de ce pays qui est la Corée du
Nord qu'est-ce que vous en pensez on dit
aussi qu'il y a toujours une femme
derrière le rideau donc en fait bien sûr
ce sont des hommes qui sont aux poux
c'est une chose être à la tête de ce
pays qui est la alors justement si le
leader actuel venait à être empêché ou
disparaître et si par exemple sa fille
devait être mise en avant pour la
représentation et pour la continuité du
mythe etc et bien l'attente pourrait
bien jouer ce rôle de peut-être de
tuteurs en tout cas jouer un rôle qui
puisse enfin permettre au système de
perdurer en gardant bien sûr cette idée
de cette famille plus que royale en fait
quasiment sacré voilà donc c'est ça qui
est très important il faut rappeler
quand même que satellite en Corée du
Nord ce clan des Kim n'existe que si la
population en fait adhère à ce mythe si
on se détourne de semis on se dit après
tout bon les descendants du Mont pectou
ils sont comme nous et voilà s'il y a
pas de sacralité et bien le système
tombe de l'Intérieur or
les gens incarnent une femme et c'est
vrai que les femmes ont joué un rôle
très important dans les années 2000 et
2020 dans un petit peu la révolution
économique et ça c'est extrêmement
important que les femmes puissent aussi
se représenter quelqu'un au niveau du
pouvoir être fier à voir un leader aussi
féminin c'est intéressant ce que vous
dites il y aurait donc une évolution de
la société nord-coréenne et l'évolution
des femmes du pouvoir des femmes au sein
de cette société
nord-coréenne aujourd'hui parce que j'ai
bien regardé il y a aucune femme
aujourd'hui qui a un haut poste au sein
de l'État nord-corure
des discussions avec Trump il y a eu la
ministre des Affaires étrangères que
l'on a bien vu et surtout bien entendu
et qui a totalement tenu son rôle donc
correspondrait aussi peut-être à une
évolution
c'est vrai que d'abord c'est la femme
communiste c'est la femme travailleuse
qui partage à charger gale l'ensemble
des responsabilités et surtout on a une
armée qui a un poids très très excessif
et un service militaire qui est très
très long et de longues périodes où
effectivement l'homme du foyer doit
s'absenter pour tout un ensemble
d'entraînements et c'est la femme qui
reste présente et c'est la femme qui
finalement amène les quelques revenus du
foyer donc elle va sur les marchés elle
vend les les revenus de la terre et
c'est vrai qu'elle s'est constituée
comme ça en agent économique extrêmement
actif comme il a été remarqué et
qu'elles sont sorties peut-être un peu
d'un rôle de suggestion qu'elles ont été
très très mises en avant et moi je
voudrais revenir aussi sur sur la
Régence
c'est-à-dire que si tu me joues un été
amené à disparaître aujourd'hui
absolument très bien elle tu prendrais
sa place à la tête
puisque au fond on a on a bien vu les
séquences organisées ou finalement
kimizung a eu le temps de préparer le
père donc de l'actuel leader à ses
fonctions l'associant très très tôt ça
faisait au moins une quinzaine d'années
qu'il était présent au côté de son père
donc on voit bien qu'il y a eu une
préparation ça semble-t-il été moins le
cas pour qu'ils ont une qui est donc est
arrivé très très jeune aux affaires et
c'est vrai qu'il y a une crise cardiaque
et une étudiant assez rapide de la santé
donc de son père et on a peut-être le
sentiment que la préparation elle a pas
eu le même temps et que ce qui explique
d'ailleurs le système de régence qui a
été mis en place à ce moment-là ce qui
explique le poids de qui donc tacle le
le beau-père sachant que l'attente était
elle aussi je dirais une région dans le
domaine économique donc on voit voilà
tout un système se mettre en place
alors dans la famille Kim maintenant la
fille c'est dans votre documentaire ça
sera le dernier extrait
n'a présenté pour la première fois en
public l'une de ses propres filles tu es
âgé de 9 ans
symbole fort c'est à l'occasion d'un
lancement de missiles Intercontinental
en 2022 que la fillette au soulier rouge
est apparue aux côtés de son dictateur
de père une mise en scène largement
diffusée par la presse nord-coréenne
en février dernier je crois cette
fameuse image alors là aussi elle a créé
beaucoup de commentaires susciter
énormément de commentaires il y a même
un timbre à son effigie qui sortait
juste après cette image en Corée du Nord
ça serait elle
vous savez dans la dynastie on brûle les
pistes mais elle a 10 ans maintenant
donc on n'est pas elle n'est pas en état
de régner si si son père venait à dire
relativement jeune il a 40 ans
la spéculation mais qu'il aurait des
problèmes de santé ils disparaît
intervalles réguliers pendant plusieurs
semaines donc on pense qu'il a des cures
il y a toute un ensemble de rumeurs
autour de lui mais ce qui est ce qui est
clair on ne sait pas ce que ce que quel
est le message réel de la mise en avant
de cette fille sinon de dire avec la
sœur et la fille que la dynastie a du du
de l'avenir devant elle parce que elle a
la relève la relève est là qu'elle soit
avec Myo Jong ou avec ses enfants et
d'ailleurs il y a toujours un mystère
sur le nombre d'enfants réel de Kim
Jong-un alors vous savez ma question
parce que j'ai vu qu'il aurait un fils
qui serait d'ailleurs l'aîné de ses
enfants
au total donc et le fils on ne l'a pas
vu c'est intéressant qu'il met en avant
sa fille dans un contexte militaire
parce que ces images sont surréalistes
on a l'impression pour le fêter
l'anniversaire de les 10 ans de sa fille
il a emmené un tiers domicile balistique
la mise en scène et et
très très soigné et très précise c'est à
la fois le symbole fort de ce régime
quel est la puissance militaire
il faut savoir quand même qu'un quelque
chose nucléaire un quart du budget de la
Corée du Nord va à la défense à peu près
on n'a pas les chiffres précis mais en
fait c'est dans cet ordre de grandeur en
France on atteint péniblement les deux
pour donc vous imaginez tous les
renoncements qu'on fait en Corée du Nord
pour assurer cette cette outil ici et
nucléaire donc sortir son présenter sa
fille au pays dans le contexte de des
des
choses les plus spectaculaires qu'a
accomplissent c'est-à-dire les missiles
et cette défense nucléaire on est dans
quelque chose de symboliquement
extrêmement fort qui est de dire non
seulement nous sommes au pouvoir nous
sommes forts puisque nous avons ces
armes mais l'avenir est assuré les
générations suivantes se préparent
lorsqu'on est chercheur comme l'une et
l'autre ça paraît terriblement compliqué
d'avoir des informations
dignes de ce nom vérifiables concernant
ne serait-ce que les enfants de Kim
juman aujourd'hui vous avez quelles
informations aujourd'hui vous concernant
cette fameuse descendance
moi je n'en ai pas personnellement mais
en tout cas c'est vrai que c'est très
façon de regarder ce que la propagande
montre et juste pour rebondir sur ce
qu'on disait sur la fille actuelle qui
est mise en avant et bien à partir du
moment où elle est mise en avant qui
myojang disparaît c'est à dire pour la
propagande il y a une femme qui incarne
et cet été on a eu la commémoration des
75 ans de la création de la République
donc populaire démocratique de Corée et
puis les 70 ans de la fin de la guerre
de Corée enfin la fin de la guerre
l'armistice plus exactement et donc pour
ces deux commémorations uniquement la
petite fille a accompagner son père
voilà pour incarner justement l'état
coréen pour incarner l'histoire commune
donc ça c'est quelque chose quand même
de d'important à noter cette fameuse
photo vous l'avez dit
l'arme nucléaire la puissance nucléaire
est indissociable de cette dynastie des
Kim c'est aussi cela qu'il y a dans la
conclusion de votre film puis c'est la
vérité et c'est vrai que ce tableau
fille perde n'a rien de touchant en fin
de compte c'est pas un tableau familial
assez classique qui nous qui nous
détendrait qui nous ferait sourire c'est
assez inquiétant toute cette avalanche
de symboles et c'est vrai que c'est
paradoxal effectivement lorsqu'on fait
de la recherche parce que on a une
avalanche d'image et des images que
auxquelles on avait peut-être pas prêté
suffisamment attention notamment les
images de la jeunesse de Kim Jong qu'on
a remise en avant et que l'on voit dans
le documentaire la période de la
scolarisation
en Suisse voilà et on se rend compte que
finalement on dispose d'un fond que la
propagande inlassablement nous nous
envoient et que peut-être on ne sait pas
déceler finalement sur l'image la
personne
importante ou le message le message a
retenir donc alors c'est la fin de ces
missions je voudrais pas la finir cette
émission sans dire tout de même que l'on
parle de l'un des niveau des plus bas
niveau de droit de l'homme au monde
concernant la Corée du Nord selon l'ONG
américaine Human Right Watch combien de
prisonniers politiques pirates qui
aujourd'hui en Corée du Nord on ne sait
pas mais le pays est un
pays unique dans le sens où toute la
population et en brigadier en régimenté
et que la marge des libertés
individuelles est extrêmement faible
même comparé à d'autres pays
totalitaires dans le monde merci
vraiment un grand merci à tous les trois
merci beaucoup pierre Aski pour ce film
que nous avons eu le plaisir de
présenter dans cette émission de abadox
vos réactions ça sera bien entendu sur
hashtag des badogues merci aussi Axel
massali qui comme à l'accoutumé m'aider
à préparer cette émission et je vous
donne tout simplement rendez-vous pour
un prochain le Badoc et ça sera bien sûr
avec son documentaire et son débat très
bientôt
[Musique]